a riparian buffer is an area around a
stream that's covered in vegetation the
buffer protects the water in the stream
from activity happening near its
location so let's imagine this a little
bit so let's say that I have a stream
right over here so this right over here
is my stream and the right Parian buffer
is an area around the stream that's
covered in vegetation so this could be
the right Parian buffer right over here
on this side of the stream and maybe
there's another one on this side of the
stream right over here suppose you run a
farm near a riparian buffer the buffer
begins s feet from the edge of your farm
and ends B feet from the edge of your
farm from your farm how wide is the
right Parian buffer so this right over
here could be maybe my farm so I got my
farm here those are my crops
those are my crops just like that
and they're saying the buffer begins s
feet from the edge of your farm so let's
actually let's say that this right over
here is the edge of my farm and it says
it begins s feet from the edge of your
farm so it depends which side you
consider to be the beginning of the
right period buffer maybe we'll take
this side to be the beginning and so
they're saying this distance right over
here is s feet and it ends B feet from
the edge of your farm so they are saying
that this distance right over here this
distance right over here all the way to
the other side of the right period
buffer is beefy how wide is the right
period buffer so the way I made my
assumptions about the the where the
riparian buffer starts and ends it looks
like it's going to be B minus s it's
going it looks like it's going to be B
minus s which would be this distance
right over there so that is B minus s
but I just assumed the buffer starts
here and ends here I could have you'd it
the other way around I could have said
hey look the buffer starts here the
buffer starts on this side and this
would be my s and I could have said
maybe it ends on this side and then this
would be the B
we really don't know which one is the
start or the end of the buffer and in
this world right over here
we would say that the difference the
difference or how wide the ripe Aryan
buffer is would be s minus B would be s
minus B but one way that we make sure
that we're going to get a positive
answer either way because we want our
distance to be positive is what we could
say look we don't know if it's s minus B
or B minus s so let's just take the
absolute value of these so absolute
value of B minus s even if we're in this
situation even in this situation right
over here it's going to give the same
exact answer as the absolute value of s
minus B it's just going to find the
absolute difference between these two
values regardless of which one is larger
so let me make that clear the absolute
value of B minus s is the same thing as
the absolute value of s minus B and so I
would go with either one of these let's
do another one dr. wen is a
time-traveling alien with a PhD in the
year 1999 dr. wen is sitting in a
sentence at Central Park New York City
and eating a hot dog he then realizes
that he's forgotten his hat to retrieve
his hat he travels t years where T is a
negative to represent going backwards in
time what do we know about the sum
$19.99 plus T so we know that T is a
negative number he's going backwards in
time so let's look at the choices 1999
plus T is the absolute value of T
greater than 1999 no that would have
been true if t is a positive number then
we would say hey this this right over
here is going to be T the absolute value
of T greater than 1999 that this would
have been only in a positive so that
would have been in the situation if T is
positive let's read this one 1999 plus T
is the absolute value of T less than
1999 that's right
imagine a situation we know that T is
negative imagine T is being equal to
negative 3 then 19 9
9 plus T would be equal to 1996 which is
three years less than so this is this is
three years less than 1999 and this
three right over here or we could write
that 1996 is instead of saying three
years less than it's the absolute value
of negative three years less than less
than 1999 so this one works out 1999
plus T it's gonna be the absolute value
the absolute vanette of what that of
that negative number T less than 1999 so
we could go with this right over here
let's do one more you're using an auger
to drill a hole for a fence post the
bottom of the hole is at a position of
negative two point three relative to
ground level so let's draw the ground so
here's the ground right over here so
let's see that's that's the ground level
and the bottom of my hole so I drill a
hole I drill a hole and the bottom of
the hole is at a position of negative
two point three feet so this position
right over here is negative two point
three negative two point three feet
relative to ground level the fence post
has a length of four point seven feet
how much higher is a fence post when it
stands atop the ground then when it is
sitting in the hole you dog so when it
is sitting atop the ground so let me
draw the fence post let me draw the
fence post when it's sitting atop the
ground the fence post looks something
like this and so when you're sitting
atop the ground it's four point seven
feet high four point seven so this
distance right over here so if I were to
draw so let me make this clear
so let me so this right over here is
negative two point three negative two
point three this right over here is four
point seven that's how tall it is when
it's sitting on top of the ground how
much higher is the fence post when it
stands atop the ground than would
sitting in the hole you dog so when you
you put this fence post in the hole you
dog it's
go down 2.3 feet so it's going to go
down 2.3 feet it's gonna go down 2.3
feet you could figure out what this
height is but they're not even asking us
this height above ground level they're
just saying how much how much does the
top go down when it's sitting in the
hole you dug so it's pretty clear that
this that this distance right over here
is going to be two point three feet it's
gonna go 2.3 feet lower when you stick
it into the hole so how much higher is
the fencepost when it stands atop the
ground the one it's sitting in the hole
you dog it's two point three feet higher
when it's stands atop the ground